every day is special for people in Gaza
who survived the 48 days of Israel's
bombardment the 4day Seas fire allows
them to check on what's left of their
shattered
lives we wish for Eternal peace not just
for days because people have gone
through too many pains and are still
suffering when we came back we found out
all the houses have been destroyed but
I'd rather pitch a tent in front of my
home than living some where else I hope
the ceasefire can last forever and as
people seize the moment for a brief
breath of fresh air trucks carrying Aid
roll into Southern Gaza loaded with food
field and
Medicine our difficulties and challenges
are not about the number of trucks
coming in but the capacity for receiving
the shipments because the humanitarian
Corridor has a very limited space which
significantly restricts the number
number of passing trucks and Personnel
therefore we request a second
humanitarian Corridor which can double
the number of trucks coming in people in
Gaza have struggled to survive with
shortages of water and other Essentials
such as gas and field the health sector
has nearly collapsed with Israel's
targeting of hospitals during the days
of
War wounded people are being sent to
Egypt for treatment
Ali make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer